One person he does not have
is his daughter,
Ivanka Trump,
because just moments
after the former
president said
that he would have run again for 20, 24
his daughter
Ivanka released a statement
essentially saying, look, I'm opting out.
She says
this time around
I'm choosing to prioritize
my young children and the private life
we are creating as a family.
I do not plan to be involved in politics
while I will always love
and support my father.
Going forward,
I will do so outside the political arena.
They are
I mean,
I remember
when there was all the conversations
of the so-called adults
in the room
and the person
everyone kept on the speed dial.
Aside from Mark Meadows
during January six,
it seemed to be Contact Ivanka.
You somehow could reel him in in some way
that's not there.
Whether that was true or not fully,
we don't know.
But that's not going to be there.
Well, neither will Jared.
Apparently, between the two of them,
they were probably three fourths
of the Trump administration
and running the decisions there.
But that's part of what we're seeing
is that even for his own family members,
the shine is wearing off
despite all of the goals
that we saw in that
assembly that that
that announcement that he had.
It's just it's
the appeal is not the same.
So what can Trump do up
to be a little bit different
and to set himself apart
from other Republicans?
Now, to the point
about his hold on the Republican Party,
it is absolutely there.
But we also saw the Trump
era drive
people out of the Republican Party.
If they didn't sign up as Democrats,
I signed up as independents.
So outside of a really raucous
Republican primary,
if Trump winning the nomination
could be a gift to Democrats. Exactly.
And you're right, as he's driven
people out of the party,
that's actually strengthened
his hold on the party
made it much less likely
that he could ever be elected again.
I mean, you don't have a Congresswoman,
Liz Cheney,
your vision
of political leadership right now
or Congress after this session is over.
And we're going to have the good night
in committee on January six as well.
But I still wonder about
not only who could take on
from the Republican side, Donald Trump.
I know Governor Santos,
he is the shiny object right
now, does not have
arguably the most formidable opponent
in his gubernatorial race,
as one would expect
at a presidential level.
But you still have to have the support
in many respects
of the Republican leadership,
the Mitch McConnell,
who I don't think is there,
the Kevin McCarthy who is undecided as of
yet, whether he will go in as
Congresswoman
Stefanik and
say, yes, I'm all in already.
When you look at the leadership
right now, in power in the Senate
and soon to be the House,
does he have the support?
Does who have to support Donald Trump?
That's what I'm talking about.
Yeah, I think he does
because for two reasons.
One, the reason that everybody
already knows is
there are many members of Congress
who are afraid to cross him
because they're afraid of being called
lil senator X or, you know,
Ron, the sanctimonious or whatever
the nickname is.
I think you also have a situation
where Republican members of Congress
don't want to be primaried
from their right.
They fear that much more
than a general election,
at least up until this point.
And so you have a situation
where you want to stay on the
President Trump's good side
so that you don't incur that challenge
lightly around the situation
you have as a Republican right now,
a Republican leader
is they embrace Trump.
And this is now
the direct consequence of several years
down the line of him
having taken over the party.
I want a lightning round here for
what do you think
the Senate is going to run,
throw his hat into the ring?
I don't think Trump will be a post
really? What do you think? Oppose or not?
I can see DeSantis running.
What do you think?
If he's going to run, he has to go now,
even though he's only in his mid forties.
Laura
if you wait too long, it's the Chris
Christie rule. You miss your window.